[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
yo guys welcome welcome welcome welcome
to a very brand new 3D Community
challenge it has been a long time coming
guys first off can you hear me can you
see me I'm looking at the chat right now
so much has went in to what we're about
to dive into guys I we we have been
working for months on this to make sure
this is as fun and as accessible as
possible for all of you guys who want to
dive in this month to figure out some
new skills some new
techniques yes guys we're doing it we
got the yes we got the thumbs up from
youall welcome welcome it's good to see
you guys um we're doing it again guys by
a show of hands we're going to let
people kind of come on in we we got
about 500 people right now um we got uh
a little email blast going out we got a
Discord blast going out we got an
Instagram blast going out they're all
probably watching the announcement video
maybe you guys have seen the
announcement video for this thing and
they're all eventually going to land
right here on the stream and we're going
to get started together on the stream so
yeah what are we doing we're getting
started we're going to go through the
project files I'm going to show you guys
the template file and uh I'm going to
help answer any questions that you guys
have about the project file about the
rules about the FAQs all that stuff I'm
here to support you guys on this 3D
Journey this month and I'm going to be
making some art alongside you guys every
Friday I'm going to live stream every
Friday this month through February all
right and I'm going to I'm going to go
for it all right you know the last
couple
challenges I fell short you know as a
lot of us did we didn't get to submit
art and I want to overcome that this
time I made this project file with Gavin
Shapiro mind you the man is a champion
the like if you don't know about Gavin
Shapiro go check him out um he's going
to be one of the judges he's going to be
it's going to be me and him judging this
thing right um me and Gavin we put
together this template file just for you
guys it's a really cool endless
staircase Loop
now what's up everybody it's good to see
you guys I hadn't made a video in uh
2024 yet this is the first one
technically the Welcome by a show of
hands I want want to see by a show of
hands we're going to do a little poll
here how many of you guys have never
done one of these before but are going
to get it this month you're going to
start today let me see you guys first
timers to these 3D challenges let me see
the
hands which is cool by the way
cuz this is our eighth one and I feel
like we learn a lot of things each time
we do it um myself and the admins put
this thing together so I got to give a
big shout out to sodon who is behind
find my computer right now virtually um
producing this live stream but sonon
shout outs to you Ronin shout outs to
you um we got cypo and we got bad cop
shout outs to you guys for helping put
all this stuff together um Gavin love
you dude thank you for helping me build
out that template file and dude we got a
lot of hands up here in chat that's
what's up yes guys yes yes yes yes
yes so good so good so good so good it's
good to see you guys
amazing true V they'll be your fourth
one that's what's up dude heck yeah heck
yeah amazing um so where do we begin
guys there's so many so many things to
talk about let's just get started with
like what the heck this is what are you
guys doing some of you guys may not have
seen the announcement video so let me
kind of walk you through what we're
going to be looking at here let me pull
up the project file I got a link for
that down below so if yall want to
download the project files right now
that's the best way to get started the
second best way to get started is to
join the
Discord let me show you about that
Discord real quick if you guys aren't on
the Discord then you totally should be
it's free let me switch over the link is
down below so let's see let's do a
little switchy switch boom Discord right
you'll hop on Discord is a little
confusing at first if you guys have
never used it before um but on the left
here you will
see these Eternal
Ascent channels and we got to get
started where you guys you know I got
the announcement video linked I got the
starter files linked you can't miss the
starter files all right I'm trying to
make it as clear as possible we got the
rules down here um we'll get into all
that stuff right um what else what else
the subm link March 3rd all the good
stuff is here we got uh feverkin coming
back to do the top 100 Montage Music we
got faq's prizes we're going to get into
all that stuff um but hop on this
Discord all right hit this little check
box get the roll that'll unlock all of
these channels for you discussion is
already popping off it's a good time
guys it's a good time all right
so Brian thanks for that super chat man
I appreciate you I missed it too I
missed it too it's a very
um like I said man a lot of work has
gone into this very moment right here so
it's cool to be doing this with you
guys yes all right let me walk you
through the files once you download the
files um let's take a look
inside all right so what we did this
time what we did this
time we SP split up the Unreal Engine
project
file and all the others okay um if you
look here at my screen and you see whoop
the files we got project files we got
references and we got a readme all right
the references and the readme those are
in the unreal file as well if you're on
the unreal side I'm going to be creating
an unreal um but if you go into project
files if you downloaded the not unreal
version you're going to see Houdini um
that sodon put together you're going to
see the Maya version which bad cop put
together you'll see the blender version
which is also a sto special um I put
together the c4d file so if that crashes
you know who to blame and then we got a
fbx for you guys as well usually we got
some um Community submitted files like
you'll see a 3ds Max come in you you
might see a Unity come in um but we'll
get to those in uh in a couple days if
they do come in usually they do right so
you're going to open that up let's go
ahead and open up the c4d file since I'm
here here it's easy let's pop it open
you guys a lot of you will be in blender
of course right so that'll be your file
of choice and so mon if you have any if
you see any questions blender wise in
chat feel free to uh to say what's up
but Soto can you say hello are you
hooked up to say what's up right
now yes I can hey guys yeah yeah dude
amazing all right guys so this is it
right
here oh you know what let me show you
the fancy version let's go to references
you'll see right here boom pull this
open and this is what we're working on
yes it is widescreen no no I lied that's
literally not what it is uh it's
vertical um what's it called portrait
mode right so we got this endless
staircase that Gavin whipped together we
got a little uh roko mocap suit action
uh smartsuit Pro 2 with the elevation
tracking coming in
handy and we got an infinite expanse for
you guys to add all your good stuff to
most of you guys have questions hey what
are the rules what are the rules um well
the rules are very simple this time we
try to keep it as simple as possible for
you guys first rule um you're going to
want to replace that character there
with a character of your own right we
don't want to use the default character
you're going to replace it with your own
character right um You don't want to
touch the camera don't move the camera
around don't try and add camera
animation don't try and make it wider
angle don't try and zoom in right and
the third one is to maintain that that
stair flow from the bottom right to the
upper middle right I guess right you're
going to maintain the stairs visual
weight okay so most of you guys will
have a lot of questions I'm going to see
him here in chat can we mess with the
stairs can we mess with the character
the answer is kind of a little bit we'll
get into it how about we get into it now
I'm make it really
clear okay so obviously the map data of
this character and the flow of these
stairs and the fact that this animation
Loops is what ties all of your renders
together it's going to tie your render
to the next artist's render and if you
start moving the character over to the
left side of the frame or you flip the
stairs to the left side of the frame
it's going to break the flow of the
montages so all these rules are set up
so that the montages flow that that's
the idea right that's simple simply put
that's the
idea
so when you replace this character uh
with one of your own characters it's
going to be walking up the stairs
exactly as you're seeing here and then
you're going to add you know some cool
steps to this thing maybe they're
walking up a rocky path maybe they're
going up like some scaffolding and you
want to try and match the steps to the
character's feet that we have here but
in a situation where oh you know my
character's feet aren't quite touching
the steps if you have to adjust the foot
animation by a hair to get it to make
contact go for it first I would probably
move the stair up toward the foot just a
little bit first the next question is
like well can I make the stairs a slope
well since the map data is taking steps
you want them to be walking up some
steps but yes you can you know modif
modify or change the steps in a way that
make it unique to yourself as long as it
maintains the visual weight the upwards
flow to the right that's the idea with
the
stairs um we got FAQs on the Discord
side of things so when you're in the get
started Channel you'll see the FAQs and
you'll see a list of
prizes and speaking of
prizes let me go over what the prizes
are cuz there are a lot of prizes this
time a lot of prizes it's pretty sweet
um there's a lot of lot of good stuff so
let me just get this over
here and we'll go through some prizes
and then I'll hit you guys up I'll
answer some questions that yall have so
um right now let me see if I can get
this right I've recorded it so many
times we got Maxon as a sponsor right
and they're hooking up the top five with
one year of Maxon one that includes c4d
of course but also zra brush um they got
you guys with the entire red giant Suite
which is amazing I use it all the time
when I'm in After Effects or Da Vinci um
it comes with forger as well and it
comes with red shift the render engine
um let's see XP pen is joining us this
time and they actually got a bunch of
prizes so for fourth and fifth they have
their Deco Pro drawing tablet the Gen 2
and you guys get to choose your size of
choice when you get up to third place
and by the way this is crazy
because it's going to take a lot you
know to get to the top five um we we'll
get to all that stuff guys we'll I'll be
hanging out with you all right I'm be
hanging out with you for the next couple
hours we're going to get all the answers
questioned all the questions answered
we're going to do it but I digress third
place XP pen you guys get their artist
Pro 14 uh drawing
display second place gets the 16inch
drawing display and first place gets
the uh where is it where is
it I believe it is the 24 in drawing
display um a good stuff from XP pen we
got um Jenga effects guys so D Jenga
effects is actually hooking everyone up
here with their entire suite for free
for the whole month so if you guys want
to use Ember if you want to use geogen
their newest like terrain
generator um for this challenge which I
think will come in handy with this
template then it's all free free for the
month so go grab it the link is in the
description it's like the fourth link
down get you guys geared up I'm going
get you guys stocked up for this thing
um Jenga effects is also giving the
artists who make the top 100 uh Montage
they're giving you guys an an extra 2
months of their D Jenga effects
suite and they're giving the top five
artists a
permanent Indie licensed towards the the
Jenga effect Suite as
well pretty sweet pretty freaking
awesome who else did we got prize wise
we got um the good people at HTC Vive
actually um is joining us this time for
the artists who make second place
they're getting you guys their Vive XR
Elite
headset um with five ultimate trackers
and a full face tracker so you basically
it's going to elevate your VR Gaming
experience you can use it to create art
you can sculpt in XR not XR you can
sculpt in uh
AR and
um it's freaking awesome honestly
they're going to set you up The Trackers
actually allow you to track your feet
your hands your hips your head all that
stuff and the face tracker of course
gets your mouth get your eyes for VR
chat and whatnot uh
roko is stepping up as well they're
hooking up everybody um the top five top
five artists with um Roco Vision a year
subscription to roko Vision which is
their two camera suitless motion capture
uh setup and by the way it is free for
the month as well for you guys who want
to do some custom map recording for
yourselves for your art r Vision they're
getting you guys hooked up so how do you
do that um first off you're going to go
to their website I got a link in the
description you're going to grab your
Coco Vision there's a 14-day free trial
if that 14-day free trial if you've
already used it up or um if you're going
to use it up then what you can do and I
got instructions I believe there are
instructions in the description and if
they're not I will add
them because they are important but here
I will tell you verbally what you're
going to do is you're going to email
support roco.com with the subject line
pisher 3D challenge all right and
they'll reup you for that 14-day free
trial all through February for Roco
Vision all right so I need to make sure
I get that typed out in the description
for you guys I just want to bring as
much value to this as possible okay I
want to help yall out as much as
possible otherwise let's see
um fourth and fifth right they got you
with that one year of Roco Vision
subscription same for third second and 1
but also if you come in third you get a
roko headset or a head rig rather um for
facial
capture second place gets um that head
rig as well uh on top of some smart
gloves to record hand and finger
tracking and first place gets all of
that plus a full performance capture
bundle which is comes with smartsuit Pro
the the gloves and the head rig as well
oh also also you guys are going to get
in a coil as well the coil is their
brand new Galaxy brain genius device
that you basically place in the middle
of your mocap uh set up your map area
and it's going to act as like a ground
Truth for all your map data and it's
just going to make your data etimes
10times 20 super accurate
um God these prizes man they keep going
Cal is in the game as well if you guys
have done these before Cal is a Turkish
design brand they have they sell clothes
they sell shirts jackets hoodies um
pants beanies this is calf beanie um
bags socks they got it all and they're
super styling they're super nice um
Turkish textiles are some of the highest
quality in the world and they're hooking
up the top five with 200 bucks toward
anything on their site and the top 100
also get a t-shirt code as they've done
in the past so shout outs to C for
coming back uh gray scale gorilla is in
the game this time guys uh freaking love
those guys Nick is amazing so grayscale
gorilla as you guys know was just for
c4d in the past but no longer grayscale
gorilla is now everywhere you do 3D all
right so all their tools assets all that
good stuff is going to be for a blender
for Unreal Engine for whatever anything
wherever you guys are doing 3D Grace
gorilla got you they got a asset library
of 4,000 plus assets they got Goos they
got IES profiles they got materials they
got models they got it all um so
definitely tap into that they got a free
trial situation going over there um or
rather a free library I think it's
infinitely free if you sign up links
down below sponsor link down below and
finally it's a big old list uh Camp
mograph is coming out again so if first
place if yall get first place
you're coming on out um we're doing it
in Chicago this year I'll be there I'll
see you in Chicago we'll fly you out pay
for the flight pay for the lodging camp
mograph in Chicago it's the best it's
like a multi-day Meetup out in nature
we're all chilling hanging out Fabricio
the winner of last year's uh February
challenge I met up with him I met up
with Sam who won fifth place and uh
David mure as well we had a nice little
endless engines meet up at camp mograph
in ch in not Chicago in
Colorado that's the prizes hope to God I
didn't miss anything um cuz there's a
lot let's check in on the chat here guys
how are you
doing let's switch on over what's up
what's up y'all what's up
y'all let me bring you over here let me
let me get I have three monitors I got
10 million screens going let's
see
boom Oh Boy all
right kinetic 1 maybe you could broaden
the winners from 5 to 10 there are so
many submissions that the winner amount
is kind of too
small um I get it I get it I get it
maybe we'll do that in the future
perhaps we will do that in the future
um not a bad
suggestion not a bad one at all Fabricio
what's up dude I see you in chat we got
melow up in here too what up
David yes what's up guys Mr one dead
duck with the Super Chat look at that
ready to get involved great prizes again
in concept what's at the top of the
stairs you
know nobody knows nobody
knows I don't know there could be many
things at the top we never see the top
you might just see a Golden Glow from
the top of the steps and never know what
truly is at the top but the question is
what's at the
bottom well te technically the next
render is at the top of the steps that's
what the that's what's at the top of the
steps yeah yeah
yeah um dude the the aanas Fabricio are
doing great man I love them they're the
best thank you
visual dude good to see you man I'm I'm
glad you like the animation so last
challenge we talked about guys it's so
difficult to do character animation we
got to just give the the community um
some map data to work with so this time
we did it we're giving you guys the map
data like we've done in the past past
couple
challenges te all right you got a good
question what is maintaining the visual
weight of the stairs what does that mean
that's that's a great question so let me
pop this open for you and
explain oh we got a car say hacky sack
shoot shoot we got to play some hacky
sack who's that from one dead one dead
duck all right we're doing some hacky
sack give me a second we're going to get
to
this sometimes you know
you just got to take a little break to
have some fun and that's what I'm going
to do right now I'm going get back to
that question what does visual weight
mean that's a great question but it's
haggy Sack
Time look at this the camp mograph
official hacky sack let me
get let me get my shoes on hold on
I think last time last time on the
stream we got like 40 or something let's
see if I kick it off with like three I
don't
know oh
God 16 17 18 19 20 1
2 all right I don't want to kick a hole
in the wall 22 is not a bad start that
is not a bad
start jeez this is the first time I got
active in like last few hours a little
lightheaded there jeez all
right what is visual weight mean great
question guys so visual weight means if
you were to imagine the stairs being
completely black and the background
being completely
white I mean I guess we could do
that right
so if we want to imagine the
stairs are completely
white let's
see that's a good enough example so that
takes up what 35 40% of the
frame so you want to kind of match that
overall shape this is taking up weight
in the frame this is taking up space in
the
frame so your stair profile might look a
little different right depending on if
you have like a a railing here or if you
um you know these steps are a little bit
bigger cuz cuz they're made of rocks up
at the top and like it's a natural Rocky
foot path your silhouette of these
stairs aren't going to be Pixel Perfect
to this but they're going to be close so
visual weight basically means that you
guys have some um some room to play
right it doesn't have to match this
Pixel Perfect silhouette depending on
how you deck out your stairs how you
make this thing unique to you you might
have some uh twigs and leaves coming off
the edge of this right as long as you
over maintain the overall visual weight
of these stairs you're going to be okay
right no one's getting disqualified
because there's a there's a little
handrail and like some leaves falling
off this side here or something or
there's a rock as the
steps that's encouraged I want you guys
to do that what I don't want you to do
is delete the stairs entirely and make
it something crazy that has nothing to
do with this um shape or silhouette or
um if you take the stairs and flip them
over to the left side right like that's
not going to
work the whole point of the stairs
keeping these stairs here is to blend
all of these renders together so that's
the idea with visual weight does that
make sense to you guys if that makes
sense give me a thumbs up in the chat if
that still doesn't make sense to
you then that maybe that's what the
Discord server for um seeing how people
push their render a little bit and
that's what our Monday meetups are for
guys every single Monday throughout the
month of
February myself the admins the
moderators we're going to be on the
Discord side of things I'm going to be
doing a weekly uh Monday at around noon
little stage chat with you guys we'll be
bringing you up onto the stage you'll be
showing us your Works in progress and
I'm going to be giving you comments on
that answering questions on your your
Works in progress you may have questions
like hey is this okay how does this look
you know and we'll say hey like work on
your lighting a little bit or you know
the silhouette of your stairs is a
little far off I think you might need to
take a look at that and we're getting
some good thumbs UPS in chat guys thank
you for understanding these rules um for
the people I'll say this for the guys
who guys and gals who have done these
challenges before and understand the
rules help out your fellow 3D artist who
is struggling and doesn't quite
understand that's what the Discord
server is for okay um it's all free and
we got you guys in a couple sweet
channels in there the get started
announcements for any updates right on
Project files if they need to be updated
um and like the working channels right
so if you've done these before um be a
good Steward help out the other 3D
artists who are just getting started we
saw a lot of first timers in here with
their hands up
um so it's a you know it's a community
it's a community of passionate artists
we're all like-minded artists we all
want to do this for fun uh we want to
dive in we want a good challenge I love
a good challenge and that is why this
whole thing started is because the idea
of just a challenge whether whether it's
a physical challenge a mental challenge
or a creative art challenge I just love
it I can't get enough and it's such a
cool way to bring everyone together to
do these things so I appreciate you guys
being interested I appreciate you guys
joining this thing we're going to have a
good time this month we're going to have
a freaking great time this month back to
the chat I'm looking at you guys right
now
okay um hit me up it's a little easier
to see if you hit at pisher but I'm
going to do my best to to read
everything and take a look at everything
all right if you guys have any questions
on how any of this stuff
works
um definitely check out the announcement
video later
after the stream I got a lot of info in
there very specific it's a shotgun blast
of all the specific info a lot of prize
info more specifics on the prizes but
also on the get started I have a
schedule there too of what I'm doing
throughout the month of February March
and even into April for this challenge
it's a long haul guys we're in it for
sure Edge dude I can't wait to see what
you're going to do I cannot wait
yes Edge man
what time is it in
Australia I don't want to
know H
H Leo so we can put stuff in the
background too right dude 100% that's
the whole point imagine it like this
imagine it everyone gets the same blank
coloring book page okay and it's up to
you to color in that coloring book page
how you see fit so yes of course add
stuff to the back background um add like
change the the the steps modify the
steps to be unique to you you're adding
the color you're adding the style the
flavor to this right that's the whole
point of
this um if you've seen any of the other
3D challenge montages that's a great
example I usually um usually in the all
renders montages if you type pisher all
renders or something um or if you just
go to the playlist of all of the
montages that I have if you look at the
all renders montages I usually start
them off with the blank template to show
hey this is what everyone's starting
with and then it gets into the art and
you see what they've turned it into so
100% that's the whole point of this and
sometimes I forget cuz we're on our
eighth one but that's absolutely the
point of this is to take the template
make it your own color it put your spin
on it make it your make it unique to you
we got super chats and I sense a card
draw coming
K what up um you see okay is there a
link specifically to the roko trial I
see the main link but I want to make
sure I go to the right place also can we
change the upper body pose and or
movement thanks two great
questions let's see let's take a look at
that link together so if you go to oh oh
oh oh oh free
assets all right here's how this is
going to go down K Adder you're going to
get one of my free asset packs whether
that's service
imperfections whether that is a bunch of
photo scans whether that is um a bunch
of concrete endless concrete
textures I may have a few other things
in the mix I think I got some like HDR
but honestly you just want to go to poly
Haven for that
um col Adder how do we even do this sod
mon they send uh I need to conf confirm
that your YouTube is connected to we'll
figure it out I got you here sod Monte
made a note we're going to get you those
free assets yeah just message me on
Discord and I'll I can handle it from
there you heard the man you heard the
man um and then your okay so your your
question on the roko link roko Vision
yes if you go down to the prizes in the
description of this video and you look
at roko Vision subscription the one your
roko vision subscription you'll see that
link there if you click that
link um it's just under products
Vision then you'll get your 14-day free
trial that'll that's like their landing
page for a Coco
Vision um and you get signed up that way
right and as far as can you adjust the
upper body can you adjust the arms can
you adjust the head of this map data
that everyone will be using and adding
their character to the answer answer is
yes you can change the head right so we
have the character walking up the steps
doing their thing um but if you want
their head to be like looking this way
instead of straight or looking up at
something as they
walk that's totally fine that doesn't
break the connection between all the
renders if you want to take their arms
and have them holding something perhaps
that's cool too but I wouldn't go past
the arms or the and that is a really
great FAQ question it's in the FAQs on
the Discord side of things if you look
at the get started Channel at the bottom
there is a thread that says frequently
asked questions and I believe that is a
character-based we have them all
categorized it's a character-based one
so very very good question yes you can
adjust the hands or the head to support
your
story all right going down the list 11
p.m. in India that's what's up I want to
visit so bad so so bad yo so speaking of
India check this
[Music]
out so I got this
book The Vanishing stepwells of India
and I I love art books guys I love art
books and um I love them because they're
great references instead of scrolling
online which you can do these are
curated references all in one package
and you can Bust It Out show your
friends you know have some tea coffee
whiskey or wine whatever you want and
have a little art book night and go
through and just get inspired put on
some good music and I was using this
yesterday to come up with some
inspiration for what I'm going to do for
my art um this this book is
incredible I so want to visit look at
[Music]
this what else we got there's a lot of
good stuff in
here oh dude so
cool and this book is just full of that
stuff
um I'll get a little bit more
into specifically
um where I'm pulling my reference from
it's art books I literally I just busted
out art books I'm on the topic now let's
talk about it all
right so I got this book um I live in
Los Angeles we have a bookstore called
Kino Kino Kunia there's a location in
New York and there's a few in
Japan so there's this book here and it's
called houses with a story and it is the
best I was flipping through this like
dude look at this look at
this and it has like all these
characters and their little setups look
at this guy
and you get like the overview of their
of their spot so I was flipping through
this and I found some really great
reference for some 3D scenes that I want
to put together for my guy check this
one
out freaking
awesome um so I think I I think I got a
little nice nice little reference Blast
from these art books big fan of the art
books if you guys want to invest in some
smart books there's a lot of good ones
out
there um I'll just take a picture with
my phone put it in pure F
and there you go there's your reference
you know questions questions I'm
scrolling would floating stairs be fine
since they don't go down to the bottom
or to the screen bottom then floating
stairs floating
stairs yeah I think um some floating
steps could be pretty sweet I I don't
think that breaks things too much maybe
there's a way you can fill in um let's
go back here to
the right so you see how this takes up
so much if there were floating steps it
would look like
[Music]
this let me do a
thing go all the way down
here
oh man come on now what's going on
jeez that makes no
sense what
what
Let's uh try that another
way okay let's just pretend all right
this would be floating steps right so
notice the difference
between that visual
weight and that visual weight so maybe
there's something you can do to fill
in these areas a little bit to play with
that visual weight there but I think
floating steps could be sweet yeah
totally totally good question can we use
Mountain stairs what are mountain stairs
like they're walking up a
mountain yeah as long as that path is
flowing in that direction in that
shape um then I don't see why not you
just want to match the footsteps of the
map data to your Rocky assets so you
would get your Rocky assets right right
up against the bottom of the feet there
that
character let's see let's
see two or more characters yes two or
more characters that is in the FAQs um
you can have two or more characters as
long as this character the provided
animation is your main character and
it's clear that they're your main
character that's all that's
all
let's see I'm going down
here um hey Alex amazing question I'm
going full screen
full full screen on this one really
really good
question we got another good Super
Chat
um Mr
Teemo much
appreciated you you have a question I'm
going to answer
um where was it Alex's question here
first we'll see if we get a little card
draw for you but Alex you have a great
question you said what do the judges
value in a 3D challenge great great
great question I will tell you exactly
how I pull the top 100 I do it with the
admins we go through we take a look we
pull the top
150 we Whittle that down to top 100
here's here's what we do we go through
render by render by render by render by
render in one long linear line and when
we see a render that catches our eye
then we we take another look at it we're
like who who hold on now hold on now
there's
something unique going on here there's
something different going on here now
what is that thing that catches our eye
I will tell you right now it's probably
lighting it's probably lighting it's
probably a little bit of
composition and it's probably a little
bit of
color so lighting that is Hu that is
huge I think first and foremost lighting
is the thing that's going to catch our
eye and make us stop in our tracks and
be like hold is this just a real chunky
render that's lit really
well and lighting won't get you all the
way but it'll it'll make a stop if you
light it nicely if it's punchy if it if
um and not to say it has to be Punchy
you can have an overcast
scene but if you're playing with your
light in a nice way contrast Shadows
highlights right all that stuff that's
going to make a stop and look at your
art the next
thing that will make or break a piece of
art in my opinion would probably be
animation now I'm already getting you
guys as far as I can with this template
file with the provided character
animation right recorded it with the
with the rcoo suit um honestly didn't
have to do any cleanup which is crazy
usually you have to clean up any map
this time no cleanup but I got it nice
and perfect for you
guys it's just a it's a smaller barrier
to entry when you have good mocap data
as the temple so you don't have to worry
about having too bad of Animation cuz
you got the great animation there on
your subject but if you're adding jets
flying by and they're like doing some
chunky thing or like if you have a
rockfall going and it's like the rocks
are janky animation is the next thing
that when we stop and look at your art
and your animation's janky it's like ah
kind of breaks it to be honest so be
aware of that all right be aware of that
now for those of you maybe that means
not doing an animation heavy render um
and just making a beautiful scene maybe
that's more of your thing
um the next thing that we look at would
be composition and lighting so how are
you stacking all these elements together
how are you placing all these elements
together are is it done in a pleasing
way or does it feel empty does it feel
like you just took the last week to put
something in and it just it feels empty
and you didn't quite get there doesn't
feel intentional doesn't feel full right
so composition is probably the next
thing that we're looking for um I would
say color as well right um are are your
colors looking pleasing do they fit your
scene and I think the topper guys for
what we're looking at for judges here
would be if you have all those things
let's say you have all those things but
you're up against 200 people who also
have those things then it comes down to
what is the unique twist is it
another you know last challenge we had
so many Oppenheimer renders is it is it
just the the 30th Oppenheimer render is
it the 80th spiderverse render or is it
something more unique to you and your
experience right not to say that those
renders can't you know exceed and
Excel but when you look at 80 of them
it's like all right look you're up
against 80 other spiderverse
dudes right so for me um story all right
story that's what it comes down to story
and a unique spin on the thing are you
doing something that other artists
aren't doing and I would say what is
your strength I would play to your
strength play to your strength on this
um I gave this advice in uh in an
interview I did a couple months ago a
month or so ago and the question was how
do you get into the top five like what
what is the what's the thing to do in
the top five and I would say look PL to
your strengths don't use this challenge
to learn 100% of the skill of new skills
use this
challenge
to this is two a two-part advice
two-part advice for the people who have
dipped their toe into 3D do what you do
do what you're good at right come to the
table with what you have in your
pocket but learn something new do
something new with this it' be kind of a
wasted opportunity if you didn't and
it's kind of hard not to learn new stuff
when you're working in 3D right there's
so much troubleshooting to be done
so many new programs XYZ right we got
the D Jenga effect Suite popping off we
got roko Vision popping off for free for
you guys this month so that's already
new stuff you guys can learn have that
new pool of learning be like 20% 15%
maybe 25% don't try and learn 100% like
I did last time I tried to learn hand
animation 2D animation mixed with like
3D backgrounds oh God it was too much I
should have done baby tests for that
style
not on during a challenge I didn't come
to the table with my strengths and play
my cards in my pocket I didn't do that
um and I didn't finish the art and I
felt kind of bummed about it in the end
so that would be my advice to you guys
on what the judges look for
lighting
animation composition and
color story and your unique twist that's
that's it um all that wrapped up in a
nutshell is it pleasing to the eye do I
look at it and go ah cool or do I look
at it and be like shoot it needed a
little bit more the lighting is a little
flat feels a little empty there's
glitchiness and popping uh animation's
kind of janky and stilted and they
should have added more samples to their
export you know there's a big difference
between those two right that's black and
white obviously there's that range in
the middle
Teemo I see you now um soda do we get a
card pull on that or
no it's going to appear shoot can you
toggle it manually by
chance has a delay okay it's pretty
intense
delay okay Teemo I see
you um can we change the character's
move and Pace on the stairs to help with
the
storytelling
uh oh wait oh I missed it I dude thank
you you know you talk a lot and you need
some water I appreciate that very much
but you have a very good question as
well it's going to help a lot of
people oh God thank you
I honestly won't drink water cuz I'll
just get wrapped up in in chatting so I
appreciate the break
man um Teemo all right look can we
change the character's movement and Pace
on the stairs to help with the
storytelling example can we make them
run uh and trip and then get back up
while fighting mosquitoes that's so
specific I love it the answer is no
however I apologize the answer is no
that would break the flow between all
the renders look at alternate realities
that is the best example look at
alternate realities top 100 or all
renders whatever is the one with the
character pulling and
walking and every render cut perfectly
it's called a match cut when it cuts
perfectly and it Loops perfectly boom
right that's what we're going for in
this so no you can't have them run up
the stairs run down the stairs do a
backflip parachute off come back up do a
handstand and then keep walking no it
has to be locked in use the you're
you're simply
replacing
the um the like default mesh character
that's in the template with your own
character now the exception of that is
like I said earlier you can move the
head a little bit you can maybe move the
arms a little bit to support your story
but not the pace not cuz cuz the music
is going to be cut to each step right
and we want that to boom boom boom syn
great question though seriously great
question um three I'm just going on the
list three asks what about the stairs
not reaching the bottom of the screen
like it's fading away um no we we we
need the
stairs this visual weit guys we need the
stairs um ending and exiting what uh we
need the stairs coming out both ends of
the frame cuz that's what um connects
all these renders together is the stairs
we're all walking up the same path we're
all walking up the same set of set of
stairs we're all
ascending together so you need the
connection sit down or stand up that's
what's up yes another break beautiful do
we have another Super Chat going dude I
hadn't scroll down in a
[Music]
minute hold on now let me just make sure
I'm caught
up Teemo you had that Super Chat and
then we had octopus skull with another
Super
Chat
and we
have S T Down Below love you brother yo
thank you I appreciate that support man
very good
stuff all right so this this must be for
octopus skull then let sit down stand
up thank you for the break my
[Music]
friend but we'll see the cards May draw
a
standup
jeez
you know I got to build in the the
personal health Cards into this thing
right yeah some of you guys get assets
some of you guys get hacky sack
sometimes you just got to sit down and
drink some water thank you octopus skull
question you have hi um do they have to
be stairs or can it be something that
gives the idea of stairs imagine a
staircase of dead people and the
character walking on top of them is that
okay or does it have to be stairs dude
that's a great idea I say that's amazing
as long as the character is stepping up
and it's moving in that fashion you
doing meat steps is your way of doing
stairs and I love it I think it's
awesome that is a fantastic
idea fantastic
fantastic and thanks for the Super Chat
by the way everyone who's who's pitching
in here on the Super Chat really helps
out very much indeed
all right y'all what do you guys want to
get into do you guys want to keep
answering questions I can probably start
blocking out a scene
um in
unreal Sandro asks is there anything you
specifically don't want to see such as
cliches that are overused I'm not going
to answer that question no way because
then no one's going to do what I say and
then you know like no no no no no no do
do you do you all right don't do
anything for me don't do anything for
the judges do you all right it's
important that you do what you love
doing all right if you try and do
something that someone else you think
someone else wants to see if you want if
you do something that like an audience
wants to see if you're doing something
for clicks
reviews do it for you do it for you all
right um and if you if all you is
Oppenheimer or spiderverse do it
freaking do it right it's not we don't
put too much pressure on this have fun
that's the whole point of this is to
have
fun um I will I would love to explore
geogen on stream I don't think I'll do
it now I'm going to get my unreal
project file going and see if I can't
block out a scene but I'm definitely
going to do some geogen later and also
um this upcoming Friday is going to be a
fun stream I'm going to be joined by um
roko Sam he's going to be coming over
virtually um I wish he would I wish he
would be right next to me on this couch
why did I say couch it's a what got you
that's what happens when you talk too
much
guys but he's coming over and we're
going to talk all
about character retargeting putting the
character onto the map data provided how
do you do that in Unreal Engine how do
you do that in blender how do you do
that in c4d we're going to be showing
you guys how to do that in all the
programs or in as many programs as we
can possibly show you um and how to you
know do the character rig uh control
Rigs and everything and unre we're going
to show you guys that so that's next
Friday all right um yes I'm streaming
this Saturday yes the live judging
stream is uh on
Saturday I believe
March I'm not going to throw out a date
I don't have it off the top of my head
the schedule is in the announcement
video
I'll get better at this I'm going to
have a card right in front of me um but
every other stream is on Friday all
right Friday at
10:45 a.m.
PST is when the live streams pop off all
right but let's do um let's let's let's
start this project file guys let's get
this thing
going all right so the first thing I'll
do I'm going
to Let's
grab the
unreal project file cuz that's the one
for me there it is I'm going to copy
this and I'm going to make a
new
folder
for uh EA
art
let's extract this
guy and see what we
see boom Unreal Engine let's open it on
up
guys get things
going so cypo put together the Unreal
Engine project file and then I hopped in
with um roko Sam and he helped me
optimize it to make things a little
easier for character retargeting for you
guys so I'll show you kind of give you a
little overview of the Unreal Engine
project
file Malicia mevan sorry if I butched
the name you are have you have questions
on resolution and frame rate all this
info is in the Discord server all right
like if you're doing these challenges
not on the Discord server it's going to
be a hard
time download Discord hop in for this I
promise you it's going to be amazing
you're going to meet a lot of cool
people a lot of young talented artists
and you guys will get all the info you
need the frame rate is 24 FPS the
resolution is either it's vertical this
time right so it's either 1080 by 1920
or 2160 X 3840 otherwise known as HD or
4K all right but it's vertical those are
the two resolutions any other resolution
in between makes judging difficult so
we're not accepting in between
resolutions but look at this look look
look look we are in Unreal Engine flying
around I'm holding right click W as s
and d q and E to move up and down and we
got a little scene here but how do we
hit play um let's go to
sequences look this is all your stuff on
the left content right you have content
you go to Eternal Ascent files that's
you all right that's all us right here
I'm going hit the sequences and we'll go
to the EA sequence and open this up now
this is our timeline boom look at that
we got a little timeline going in here
and if we hop into if we
unscrolling boom look at that hit play
Let's go to our cinematic timeline I'll
go to perspective cinematic
viewport po back into that camera we hit
play we got all our our uh little tools
and buttons right in here so look at
that we got our nice little Loop we hit
this Loop button on the
right this is unreal 5.3 update your
crap if you ain't updated already it's
an amazing version amazing software if
you're on four who's on four these days
probably people still building their
game in four from all those years ago no
shade not at all I wouldn't know cuz I
don't I don't make
games um but look at that right okay um
we're going to get into specific how to
add characters to this on the upcoming
Friday stream with Sam from Roco but
what I do have for you guys if you check
this out characters we have the ue5 mesh
and the ue4 mesh but you can't see them
that's because they're turned invisible
if you select this
mesh and we type
visible and we check it on and would you
look at
that we have the unreal five
mesh right and I'm going to turn off our
EA template guy so it's this is our
unreal five guy and we can add control
rigs to this we can tweak you know um if
the shoulders look too crunched you can
kind of fix that if you want to adjust
the head a little bit like we were
talking about earlier you can do that
with control rig all that good stuff
right we also have the unreal 4 version
for you as well but we in unreal five so
any character mesh um or skeleton that
that is compatible with the unreal 4
skeleton or the unreal 5 skeleton you
guys can easily parent that stuff on
here again be getting into that this
upcoming
Friday what
else oh there's a little lighting cut
that's just a little pop pop it's just a
little it's fine it's just unreal being
like thinking real hard in the
viewport
um what else is there to get into I mean
that's that's basic right here's another
thing here's another thing in Unreal
Engine when you export right you're
going to export the little clapboard
movie render Q right we got it enabled
for you boom open this up and what we
have for you if you click on the
settings we want to change our render
settings if you load up in the top right
here the Eternal Ascent basic render
settings I click
that and technically this is wrong it's
exporting 200 frames this should be
unchecked
this should be unchecked does that
warrant a new Unreal version maybe I
don't know we'll get
there but we see it's in 24 FPS and it's
frames uh either 0 to 119 or frame 1 to
12 the point is it's 120 frames no more
no less I have a very in-depth video on
how I technically judge these challenges
it's on the Discord side if you read the
started page under the submission area
you can read how I am judging it and
what will get you booted from the all
renders montage and what will keep you
in the all renders Montage what keeps
you in the all renders montage is just
following the rules especially the
technical rules 24 FPS the resolution I
just mentioned and um the duration 120
frames only all right I get into what if
you you go one frame over I get into all
that in that video on the Discord side
look on the Discord side all
right but these are just basic render
settings for your export
um but maybe let's build something out
um how you guys doing in chat you guys
feeling good if you guys are with me
right now and you got your project file
open and you're looking at some
reference and research let me see a
little hand
raise I want to see you guys see you
guys working
I love it Discord is popping off too we
got a lot of people on the Discord
side having a good time getting
amped elf Elfen Stein yes you know the
training video on how to avoid the pit
of
despair what up John jagsy what's up
dude you going to be at camp this year I
hope you going be be a camp this here
but thanks man I appreciate it thanks
for the
support yes yes yes I see the hands in
chat love it Sandro good question if you
add a little sound effects but no music
will it be judged or are their videos
muted the videos are muted my friend you
can add sound effects and music for your
personal reels and all that good stuff
but all of these pieces of art will be
judged without sound I um they won't be
factored into the judging experience so
if you do the best sound design ever and
your your artist friend next to you
didn't do any you don't get a bonus
because you did sound so it's all judged
muted Paul
thorough you know I'll say this is a
good question can I make it horizontal
it's more
cinematic no you cannot you must
maintain
Within These parameters you must fit
your unique spin in these parameters
right portrait mode character
animation camera doing its thing don't
touch the camera right these elements
are locked so that all of the art flows
together if you watched any of the 3D
challenge montages before you'll get a
good sense of it imagine if you're
watching a montage and all of a sudden
there's a fli the video that's not going
to work that's not going to work but I
say that's a good question my friend
that's a good
question um I you know we've done eight
of these so far so there are times where
I need to think back to the first one
you know some people don't know the the
answers to these
questions it's good question good
question it's no bad question y'all it's
only a bad question if you're
asking the these questions that are
obvious in the FAQs there if you don't
read the rules and you're asking on week
two that's a bad question do a little
work read the FAQs read the rules all on
the Discord side and we try and bake it
into the project file as you see here
too um s mon
I i' I'd like your input on this
question so they say all right um not
sure if this has been asked yet but if
we want to make a character that doesn't
fit with the map data such as like a
Lego or an animal can we re rework that
that character as long as it matches the
map data how do you feel about
that I think so I think it would be cool
to see yeah of course cuz a Lego can't
move the they AR arms in in the same way
so I think so just make sure that it
feels like it's the same animation just
in the Lego style instead of a complete
completely different animation let's say
yes exactly if we're going through the
judging process and we see a Lego
character but it's like doing the same
thing but technically you had to had to
go off book and and rework it to to
match like in my mind I think yes I can
see it I can see a version of My Mind
where that's okay um
if you if it's not close to the
animation that I provided then you know
if it's too far off then that's a risk
that you're taking right so we we do say
this a couple times yes this is a
challenge right yes there are
rules it's up to you as the artist to
determine how far you want to push that
um a rule a rule break or a rule twist
right it is a creative
risk
um so I'd say to the artist discretion
right but that's why I'm here to help
I'm going to try and help you help guide
you I can't be sitting here and say oh
no you need to tweak the animation a
little bit like that in order to be good
except in the Monday um meetups I will
probably hit you up with some of those
specific notes in the Monday meetups on
Discord side okay
um
so yeah be aware be aware of
[Music]
that all right y'all let's see if we
can't build out a little something also
by the way if you go in the sequencer
and you go to negative
frames then you'll see see that we have
the character data hit a t
pose or a pose technically for unreal
they're in their a pose that's going to
let you retarget the character nicely
and then they're slowly moving toward
frame one so that if you want to do any
simulations etc etc those simulations
are happening slowly over time so that
when we land here it looks natural right
we don't get this weird pop if a frame
was frame1 and then you go to frame zero
then you're going to see a weird pop in
this in the uh there's no rest time for
your for your simulations if you're
doing close now in blender in Maya in
c4d um the toost frame is -1 that's
that's on a negative one frame and
technically if you want to simulate
clothes from negative -1 T POs to frame
zero let's go it's going to blow up your
program that those clothes are flying L
of space you would want to walk that -1
T pose frame back 100 frames or is
however many frames you want so that you
can simulate from frame negative 100
boom it comes into place and then now
you're walking same thing for motion
blur if you're going negative one t pose
to the next frame pop right this break
neck speed into your walking your motion
blur is going to be there's going to be
like a ghostly remain of the T pose on
your frame one
so be aware of that slide that negative
one key key frame back a little bit to
avoid that if need be
[Music]
okay oh
boy all right all right all right let's
let's get into a little bit of art I'm
also going to be judging the weekly
challenge art um from last
week which was to recreate a painting we
saw some really good pieces of art so
I'll be judging that at the end of the
Stream but let's see if I can't get a
blockout going based on some reference
that I
pulled speaking of reference let's get
that pulled up let's do it so anytime
guys I start a new project by the way if
you're not doing this I got a little
quick access over here you
can go to that folder drag it put it on
top boom right I also got all my stuff
organized by year so we're in 2023 minus
like the 20 or sorry we're God we're in
24 oh
we're in 2024 I got four projects in
2024 already but these are the remaining
remaining projects I'm still working on
from 2013 right so that's just kind of
the way I do things right I'll have it
one through four kind of a deal like
that
um so quick access bam right there I'm
going to do a ref folder for reference
and we're going to open up pure ref
which is free and it's a great way to
drop in a bunch of reference here
so let's let's go ahead and let me
pull my
reference from
iCloud and I'mma log in here you
Scoundrels will steal my iCloud if I
show it on
screen each and every one of you
jeopardize all right now you do to the
pass key hold on hold
on
I'm going to get this reference I show
you guys it's from that book that I um
that I showed you this house with a
story book there we
go all
right we're
in let me grab my photos real quick and
we'll get blocking out in Unreal
Engine
here we go let's grab these guys
download pop it
in workout oh we got a workout we got a
workout plann yes like I said mental
health guys it's important it's
important all right Let's do let's do a
little workout together all of us
artists some of you have already done
your workout for the day others never do
workouts now is the time to do another
workout or your first workout in 12
years Let's Do It um sorrow riffs I'm
going get to your question here it's not
even a question it's just a what's up
you got to catch the live stream finally
welcome I'm glad you did um thanks for
the videos you got it and how do I enter
your weekly
challenge um weekly challenges are held
when we're not doing these big 3D
Community challenges these 3D Community
challenges are month-long challenges
they happen twice a year in February and
in August those are the working months
for those we're in February we're doing
a 3D Community challenge the weekly
challenge is any other time we're not
doing these big ones so we're not doing
weeklys yet or at this moment but you
just hop on the Discord hop onto my
Discord it's free um we got the weekly
challenges popping off for you guys
every week um the admin team the mod
team are amazing they help set it up we
get you guys on a new prompt every
single week and then I judge it when I
try not to be late but I'm late a lot of
the times I'm sorry for the artists who
are waiting on my judgment um but I'll
judge them in a little video talk about
your art give you little tips little
praise that's how you do it it's on the
Discord side but I owe you a workout and
so do the other artists here what do you
guys want to do let's take a boat I'm
going to make a poll what workout do we
all want to do
together let's see let's start a little
poll um it's a yes or no
question let's add an option how about
that um we
want which workout do you want to
do we can
do 10
burpees we can
do
um 50 jumping jacks or we can
do 20
push-ups start the poll what do you guys
want to
do what do y'all want to do for the
workout we owe sorrow Rifts some
calories let's see how many calories we
can let's do the let's do the the the
the calorie based 3D workout right we're
going to do how many calories can we
burn in a month collectively can we burn
enough calories to light a house on
fire that's the question y'all y'all
okay push-ups you want do push-ups we'll
do push-ups we'll do push-ups let's do
some push-ups if you voted you better do
some push-ups we're doing 20 all right
do them however you want we can do
standard we can do tricep we can do the
hardest ones um one leg lifted for 10
other leg lifted for the other 10 I want
to see you guys doing some push-ups
let's get to
it all right I'mma Jam myself into the
back of my room here here we
go 20 20
push-ups oh boy oh
boy
jeez
okay good ones too good ones chest got
to touch the ground you can use your
knees too you know if if you can't do 20
push-ups go to your knees like this try
and get 20 there's a knee verion
boom ah all
right I think that was 20 maybe it was
21 I don't know I
forget it was 20 it was 20 it was 20 all
right guys that's what's
up all right if you got your push-ups
in give give me the the the arm Emoji if
you got your push-ups in guys let me see
it let me see it how many how many of
you guys burn calories we burn calories
together How We Do
It
yes thank you
sorrow
for the workout I love it thanks for the
Super Chat as
well Connor you're obsessed with that
tree dude you ask about every time we
stre every time it's a little Lego
Bonsai look at that a little Lego Bonsai
I got to add the Sakura leaves to it
pretty soon here yes guys we got some
push-ups
in yes
10 + 10 equals 20 is all good look do it
how you 5 plus 5 plus 5 + 5 right all
good you guys got your push-ups in we
burn some calories together I love
it
yes
yes MD
Studios you got that 20 in I appreciate
that man that's cool that's
cool all
right let's get our reference
going I love it guys the last four were
hard two extra that's what's up
dude that's what's up I like that do you
guys like the this card system the
raffle card thing I feel it's a fun way
to do the super chats right makes it
makes it a little
interesting and also we get to work out
together I like that it's fun all right
back to the work back to the work here's
my art I lied I didn't make this it's my
reference is what I
meant pure F here's some little
shortcuts select everything if you do
Control Alt up Arrow it'll size
everything the same and then contrl P
will snap everything together all right
so here's what I'm thinking this isn't
all of the
reference I got one more
one more
bit here we
go select everything Control Alt up and
then control P I do it every
time all right so here's what I'm
thinking right I guess this is a cool
view of like
it's even on the right side right so the
characters on the right and what I love
about this is the fact that they're
playing with the midg ground detail with
this Gorge it's a it's a big Gorge it's
not just flat ground all the way up it
it's adding depth to the scene and I
think that's really cool I want to play
with that a little bit right so that's
my first idea is to incorporate like a
big Gorge big something big elevation
change right here with some Cliffs I
think it's some real nice visual
contrast to give give us something cool
to look at right the next thing I want
to do is play with this lighting where
everything underneath is foggy and Misty
but only the things that are super tall
are hit by the sunlight I love this kind
of um this kind of vibe I think it's
cool so I'm going to try and play with
this style of lighting and finally I was
looking at the Lighthouse I thought it
was a cool way to justify some circle
steps so maybe there's some Lighthouse
Vibes on that I don't know
I don't know first thing is trying to
get this lighting and this blockout
going so that's my goal right
now I'll switch back to
the
yeah all
right put this where did I put there's
so many I got three screens I don't know
where to put is jeez all
right so under cameras in Unreal Engine
what we have is uh a key frame on this
camera camera so if you're in this
camera view right so this we're out of
the camera view flying free G by the way
will show or hide icons on the screen so
we can see our camera path is going
along this this little path over time
right boom if I was in this camera and I
didn't have this key frame here under
the transform option on the camera if I
move
this like I'd be screwed that's why you
want to duplicate your project make a
backup but in this case we have a key
frame so it's going to snap back right
that's a good thing we want that but
let's take a look here let's let's um
hop
out and see if we can't build out like a
little blockout situation for this do we
have content starter
content we don't have starter content
but that's okay we can add it by going
add add feature or content pack and
content starter content We'll add this
to the project starter content gives you
a lot of like starting
materials um little sound effects uh and
in my case what I want it for is the
wall object starter content gives you
the
wall and I'll bust out this wall and I'm
going to build out my scene my block out
my scene with these walls so um in
Unreal Engine if you hit space bar it'll
transfer between all the gizmos all
these gizmos right so scale position
rotation and I'm going to go ahead and
like scale the heck out of this
this and try and get some sort of
horizon line going um in unreal let's
grab that
wall and in our details panel we can
probably scale it up
999 across the
board um the height though probably
don't
need the
height that much so I'll just yeah
that's that's far that
goes right I'll bring this out here and
I
[Music]
think I'm bring it
down you can change your camera speed in
the top right or I think middle Mouse
wheel also controls camera speed we can
just back this way off kind
of get this lined up center right so
we're looking out and if I go back to
sequencer I can hop back into my scene
and kind of see what we're looking at so
we have a ground plane right successful
ground plane I'm going to get rid of
these rules cuz I know
them boom
boom and then let's get rid of that um
let's try disable
all what did it
say like we're not seeing it anymore
okay whatever
all
good stop
it disable all screen
messages disable all screen messages is
that how it
works
cool
um so I want to build that Gorge setup
with another wall so I'll go back to
content browser bust out a
wall
and let's try
this up by
100 and see like how see if we can't
build out this like shelf holding alt to
duplicate space bar to cycle to my rot
ation Gizmo space bar again for my
position right so this is our little
setup I can group this with I believe
contrl g yep so we select it contrl G
it's
grouped and let's see we can't hop back
into camera cuz all of this is just from
camera view
right at what point
does this turn into like that Gorge
looking thing and right
now we're like kind of seeing
it let me change the
lighting so I love what's
called uh Ultra Dynamic Sky all right so
I'm going to show you guys how awesome
Ultra Dynamic sky
is Ultra dnamic sky is the best
way let's see where is
it it's my favorite way to light stuff
Ultra Dynamic Sky we're going to add to
project template add to
project and we should have it Ultra
Dynamic Sky boom here we go we'll clear
our search I'm going to find Blueprints
and scroll down until we see Ultra
Dynamic Sky drag it
out let go and boom we got Ultra Dynamic
Sky popping off I'm going to delete all
of this lighting stuff here cuz I don't
need it
anymore cuz Ultra Dynamic sky does
everything we can change the time of day
in Ultra Dynamic sky in real
time we can change let's get a better
something we can change um the cloud
coverage in Ultra Dynamic Sky we can get
a bunch of clouds make it super foggy
change the fog boost it up to like 10
make it super foggy um you can take it
to nighttime in Ultra Dynamic Sky let's
get rid of the fog cloud coverage and
it's we got a night scene with stars out
here it's just the best right and
there's infinite things you can do with
ultra Dynamic
Sky Sandro yes camera Shake is okay keep
it tasteful but yeah
um technically camera Shake doesn't
really count as don't move the camera
that's an exception I guess to that rule
camera Shake is
chill all right let's see
um let's get this Gorge going how is it
in the the
reference kind of like overcast I guess
right there's some clouds out there we
do want to aim for this lighting
with this kind of geometry of a of a
setup so we'll bring
out our
[Music]
wall control back tick will change your
Gizmo orientation from local to World
back tick is the button that is to the
left of your one key at the top of your
keyboard that's pretty
cool if we bring it
closer
something like
that we can change a little bit more
cloud
coverage and we might even be able to
like rotate this a little bit
more something like that yeah and then
this
wall
can extend out
infinitely so maybe what we do is a
little switcheroony on
this so we can right click go to groups
and ungroup it right we kind of got it
in place I'm going to take this
floor
and I'm going have this floor
be the thing that goes
infinite so I'll bring this up
and then this guy can be our like our
ground plane that's just in the
foreground there we go look at
that remember G will show our hide icons
we'll go f11 for full
screen right we're starting to get that
that's really cool nice little Gorge we
can have a little village down there
little town
um another good reference
actually I'm just thinking of
[Music]
is let's take a look so I have this
folder which I should totally upload to
my patreon at this
point but I have this
folder um let me see if I can find
it
archive let's
see
um what it be VFX ref reference where no
it's
archive
pictures here we
go
cinematography this is it all right so
back when I worked at Rocket Jump
um and was having to do a short like
every week or
two and we had to do all aspects of it
where we had to light it we had to you
know direct VFX everything you know
YouTube channel
right and I realized I didn't know
anything about
lighting and the easiest way for me as
an artist this is even back to when I
was like a a little
kid when I was drawing I would always my
way of learning was to look at another
drawing and copy it right and I know a
lot of us are like it's interesting it's
interesting right because with 3D it's
like you're not going to you're not
going to look at someone's render copy
their render and then say it's yours
it's theirs right so it's a little
different when it's for Education I'm a
kid I'm looking at drawings doing a
drawing Boom showing that or drawing a
photo or something right it's pretty
onet to one great way to
learn and what I did for lighting was I
pulled movies that I loved and I was
looking at the lighting and this was our
way of if we wanted to light a scene how
they do it in the movies you look at the
movies you love and you ask yourself how
is it lit and a lot of this is very
naturally lit right this of course not
but look at how great it looks it's
perfect um they're probably doing a lot
more than just these two lights but
maybe not sometimes you get lucky and
that's that's just the case um so what I
did is I believe I have Castle in the
Sky
[Music]
what
I don't have Castle in the Sky oh J it's
under its
own and there's a shot in
here of like this
town let me go
through oh this is all such a good
reference such a good
reference if you've never seen this
movie watch this movie
this this this these little side towns
on the mountain and like this down here
yeah this is coming into the reference
this is coming into the
reference um where are
you yeah these
guys but like so cool
this this right here dude this right
here
amazing but yeah if you've never seen
this movie definitely check it out it's
one of the best might be one of my
favorites so good yeah it's a Cool vibe
Cool vibe for
sure Keanu
Steve I see you just started blender and
you're planning on joining that is the
best case scenario it's a great way to
learn your program it's a great excuse
you have 30 days and look even if you
figure out how to add um a sunlight to
your scene and replace the character and
make some dirt on the ground and hit
render if that's your way to learn do it
do it do it do it even if you learn how
to just hit export on something I
promise you'll learn more than that but
if you take these 30 days and you know
commit yourself to completing a render
and you go easy on yourself go easy on
yourself all right don't try and do the
biggest craziest thing do something
that's achievable that's
attainable and
um yeah dude honestly best way to learn
best way to learn I tell that to my
buddies who are trying to learn blender
I have um you know the very very good
dude um his name is Matt he's the guy
who who edited the last handful of
videos that I put out on the channel he
edited the announcement video he's
trying to learn blender I'm like dude
this is the way join the challenge learn
something new learn how to hit render
all right learn how to add a sunlight
hit render that could be day two day one
even think of all the other things you
could do so it's a good way to do it
it's like um and you do it with the
community too right I don't know if I
need to keep giving you guys a reasons
to do these challenges we're all doing
them but I just think it's cool like you
know when a game comes out and
everyone's playing that same game
together and you're like oh there's a
secret area here I didn't know that that
or like you hop in with your friends
it's the same thing it's the community
side of things behind these challenges
that make it so cool so thanks for
joining guys I appreciate
it Sandro your mind is
blank um this is another thing that we
say
so you don't have to have an answer you
don't have to have the direction you're
going on day one I am a little bit
fortunate in the sense that like you
know I've known about this challenge
obviously since I'm hosting it so I had
a little bit of an idea and one of my
goals was to have some idea for this
stream
today um so I'm a little ahead in that
sense there are other people like
um I'm not going to call anyone out I
don't want to I don't want to you know
jinx anything but there are there are a
few artists who choose to take the week
the first week to come up with the best
idea they'll think of 20 ideas and
they'll go for that one idea that stands
out and technically I should probably do
a little bit of that myself I'm going
into this with an idea that I think
could be fun I'm going to just follow
that spark for now and you know I'll
I'll come up with something else if I
need to or I'll do a little bit of
brainstorming but here's the thing is if
we're working on this every day chipping
away at it a few hours each day then
it's going to be in the back of your
mind you'll be thinking about it it's
just like if you're writing a story or
working on any project long term it's
it's sitting in your mind it's you know
you're pondering it over these weeks
over the month and um you might halfway
through like I know visual right halfway
through during endless engines I think
it no no no it was a infinite Journey
he started a render and like ditched it
halfway through maybe even had been
closer to the deadline and he got top
100 when he he just switched his idea I
was like this is a better idea and it
takes a lot of guts to do that um and I
think it takes someone with a lot of
skill and knowhow and like you got to
know what you're doing if you're going
to switch your idea and still expect to
submit um but it's possible you know not
not ideal but if who's to say what's
ideal I don't know it works for him
so hey so sleep you have been having an
art block since moving meditation and
now you're inspired hopefully this keeps
up that's what's up man heck yeah heck
yeah I will only um I'm not only going
to say I say a lot to that but I I've
burnt out every year um since the last 3
4 years since rebooting the channel uh
didn't burn out last year though that is
that was the key that was the thing that
I was surprised about and um is because
of this book
The let me get it
wrong is the artist's way the artist's
way and it's like a 12we workbook where
you get through your creative blocks and
is the best I loved it I'll recommend it
to anybody one of the things that it had
you do is just take an artist date is
what it called once a week and that's do
something with you and your inter
yourself alone for x amount of hours um
on this on this date right and um the
goal is to just do something that's fun
don't do it for Instagram don't do it
for views don't do it cuz you think you
should do it cuz that's what you think
you want to be doing do what's fun go on
a creative date with yourself and that
is that was just like a huge answer for
me was that I wasn't having fun I wasn't
playing that's the idea is
play so if this challenges a way for you
to play then even better um but make
sure you're getting that that playtime
right um whether it be through this
challenge or through you know making
music or going on Hikes and doing some
photography whatever have that play time
for yourself it's
important I mean this art dude this art
is looking cool I'm already happy with
like the setup we can go one further if
you want to do like something like this
let's see let's hop out of full screen
let's follow that jibli reference a
little bit
more and see about adding another Cliff
face at the
front
um the
[Music]
heck that was weird okay
um yeah let's see about adding another
Cliff
face at the front so I'll take this guy
bring it
up and just so navigation is easy let's
do it like
that and see what this does for
us so we're missing the ground by right
click here we can go to Pivot and
set
you have to set the pivot offset and
then set pivot offset
here it's a little
confusing oh it's like not on the object
that's
weird I have this set up let's see pivot
is shift Q alt shift
Q shift Q alt shift
Q so odd why why is
it hovering it's like um it's like I
don't
have you know when you place something
on a uh surface and it
sticks it's not doing that I think I
need to toggle
something what is that
toggle it's up here
somewhere what is it shoot it's when
it's like uh like stick to
something surface snapping there it is
right there boom surface snapping so
technically that would
mean if I try this
again what is it shift Q alt shift
Q
what dude why is it not working
huh all right well I guess we'll just do
it uh the long
[Music]
way that's ridiculous it's like I I have
to be right
here
there we go so yeah there's like a ledge
here or
[Music]
something so just playing with playing
with the depth of everything right
that's the
idea
so maybe this is like a
watchtower that the character is going
up with a village down
there and then you could have
like
some Let's do let's hop out of
this and technically the good thing with
Unreal Engine is I I technically don't
need to be doing this with blocks like
this I could be doing this with
actual
geometry cuz it's all real
time
just playing with the big
shapes
[Music]
oh
maybe there could be like a dam here or
something and there's like water on the
other side or I I don't
know
that's pretty sweet I'm a
[Music]
fan hip hop shot I got you man
absolutely yeah I the reason I'm
streaming I I want to help you guys out
throughout this challenge I don't want
to just hit you with an announcement
video and dip out for a month like it I
want to do this with you guys cuz I do
need the the push and the support myself
is better with a community so um yeah
thank you guys I appreciate
you this is fun though um let's see
reference
wise I know he has his little Watchtower
too I
think let's go
back
[Music]
to the jibli
reference yeah he like rolls up into
this little Watchtower thing that he's
got which could be a good excuse for the
stairs oh man that's so
good another great
reference yeah this
guy so good so good
let's grabb all that let's grab that
stuff
sweet ear
fu sorry if I Butch your your name thank
you for the Super Chat you say um how
far can we create realistic
metahumans um are you saying how do you
create realistic metahumans or can you
use them you can certainly use them
that's for sure in terms of how you
create them I got into metahumans on
like day one I did a live stream with it
and I hadn't touched it since so I can't
tell you too much about metahumans right
now I know metat TR um who is one of the
mods on our server fantastic artist he I
think is pretty familiar with uh with
the metahuman workflow but man there's
lots of tutorials out there for sure if
you want to check one
out dark Productions will there be a
video made to help replace the character
as in the previous challenges yes next
Friday this upcoming Friday in fact I'm
going to hit you with a
[Music]
date the 9th Friday the 9th we're going
live at 10:45 a.m. PST like right about
now uh it's me and Sam from roko and
we're going to show you or rather he's
going to show me how to add a character
to this data here in Unreal Engine
and he's going to show us uh we might
have sodam mon show us blender and I'm
going to show you guys c4d and we're
basically all going to just show you how
to add characters to as me in as many
programs as possible that's next Friday
okay the 9th Friday the 9th be there for
it the video will be on YouTube forever
so if you guys want to um if you can't
make it you ain't going to miss it all
right you ain't going to miss
it
amazing
amazing Andrew can you enter more than
once no one submission per artist please
one submission per
artist um we want to encourage you guys
to put your creative effort into one
thing and not split it up amongst three
things um I think it makes the montages
look better in the end and I think it's
a good exercise for us to focus on
creating piece of art over a month
um you know it's a different it's a
different Rhythm it's a different pace I
like it I think it's
fun are there age requirements for the
challenge technically no in terms of
like prizes if you win if you're 12 and
you win first place and there's
technically only one ticket to Camp
mograph how do I feel about flying a
12-year-old out to camp mograph on their
own not good
uh you technically would need a
chaperone for that
um I mean 18 and above for that I'd say
look let's let's talk about it when we
get there if it comes down to you uh
flying out to Camp
mograph you know do you come with a
parent or not it's happened in the
past um and it's been super chill so you
know in terms of winning other prizes
nah not really
there's no age restriction on
that um you know top five just get some
prizes sent to them they get some
software uh emailed to them right so I
don't think you need to be 18 to get
software uh I don't think you need to be
18 to have tablet shipped to you I could
be wrong but I don't think so I don't
believe that was a a requirement so yeah
I want to keep it open to
[Music]
everybody
uh Vishnu can the character hold
something yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
only thing you can mess with on the
character animation are the arms and the
head so if you want the character to be
holding something and looking at the
thing they're holding then yeah that's
that's cool that's totally fine you just
can't change the pace of their steps up
this staircase or in your case it could
be uh destroyed Tower or a Mountainside
or whatever make the stairs your own
keep the movement flowing up into the
right um but yeah you can move the arms
to be holding something if you'd like
that's
cool
h
all right what should we do from here um
maybe we can play with some of the
lighting let's
see it'd be cool to get that slice
across just the tops
of what's the best way to do
this like where it's just hitting the
tops of these guys and I might have to
really play with some
stuff zero fog zero
clouds how do I get that
slice
um cuz you see it's hitting here maybe
if I take these oh I know I think I just
need to rotate this
there it is
[Music]
peeko
so the question is how to get
it so it's just hitting the tops of
these
only
[Music]
and we just keep cranking this number
from 610 to 611 no no
[Music]
600 the 600 gets these
guys um
okay
598 technically that's it 5
98.5 five
99 and I 5
97.5 oh it's so
thin 5
six
57 58 oh it's between
that it's like razor thin um
597 and
598 so we go
71 72 Maybe there's a better way of
doing
this but right now this is all I know 75
I believe
79 dude
what
okay
799 7 95 I'm just trying to get that
halfway point
jeez I guess the true way to find out is
if
we
move this up and down ah that weird
thing uh can I take
this
yeah I think that'll take some some
playing with for sure but this is cool
we can get some vdbs down here some
Cloud
vdbs
H let's see what the fog does for us
cloud
coverage that's
beautiful
so I want it to be like kind of
overcast except for that hole in the
clouds and it might just be its own
light doing
that yeah cuz I want the fog to be like
in the foreground but the sunlight to be
in the back ground so I'm going to
really have to Art direct it to get that
look
going we have some vdbs down here some
little foggy BBS will be
sweet
sweet I love it I'm I'm loving
it that's cool Sandro good question what
was your guys' first 3D challenge moving
meditations that was a good one feverkin
by the way the guy who did the music for
the top 100 he's coming back and he's
doing music for this one too so it's
bound to be bound to be good no pressure
anything Adam if you're watching
this the falling ball one was the first
one that's Dynamic
machines
yeah um fod asks what theme am I going
for I don't know yet I don't know yet I
think that will kind of be determined as
I
go maybe some nature fantasy Vibes but
usually I don't go for the fantasy Vibes
usually it's dark and Moody and uh not
that that can't be fantasy but we'll see
we'll see don't know
yet
um James I'm not trying to Loop the
background no I'm not trying to Loop the
background that would be crazy though it
it's possible honestly it's possible
let's say actually no it's not possible
because because of this the angle on
that won't
match the angle here won't match
either
unless I animate that to match with the
camera I can get the background to move
uh to be the same if I put these
guys basically in the same spot move
these
over as long as your first
frame matches your last
frame but already that looks so drastic
there's a big difference
between between that so it it definitely
take some playing to get that to to
match but no this doesn't this render
doesn't need to
[Music]
Loop settle field yes you can play with
dep the field that is very very
possible can you do some 2D animations
at top any renders
absolutely yeah if you want to spice up
your I mean we we've had the guys do
full 2D
animations um guy Collins I'm looking at
you and if it's sick it's sick you
know sandre what's the first challenge
that I that we did so the first
challenge that I did was called um
alternate realities if you
look um no that was that's a lie usually
I get these right parallel Dimensions
was the first one that's the one with
the mountain and a character walking
towards the mountain and that was uh
almost 4 years ago I don't know man
that's
crazy and if you look in
the 3D Montage playlist I have on my
channel it has them all so you can go
back and take a look at those but
they're in order they're in order from
you know time
wise one point what uh
um you have a good question he says hey
Chad I have a question what inspired you
to get into 3D into the 3D modeling
field I'd be
curious about your guys's
answers um for me it was like when I
realized that I can create anything I
saw in my head in 3D granted I have the
technical skill that takes time but it
was just the idea I could do anything
sky is the limit and that was just the
coolest thought to me such a liberating
freeing thought and I'm like man it's
it's all possible with 3D art and uh
yeah I still feel the same way today
it's so cool you can create anything you
want I love it I love it so
much all right guys I
think I'm going to hop into the weekly
challenge
art we can take a break together take a
look some look at some uh Recreations of
some paintings that some of the Discord
artists put together I'm going to go
over some honorable mentions and I'm
going to get
into
um five winners after that I'm happy to
take a little bit more time with you
guys to answer any questions any like
final question blast that you have and
then I'm probably going to call it and
grab some food here guys
so let me save all my
stuff save save
save all right so the Monte are you uh
feeling good here to start some weekly
challenge
winners all right let me get you full
screen on
here and we'll take a look all right
guys so
The Prompt this last week was recreate a
painting and uh we got some really
really great art it's always difficult
to pull the top five winners for the
weekly challenge and this is the last
time we're going to be doing the weekly
challenge until this challenge is done
in March all right um so no more weeklys
we're focusing on the monthly the
community challenge the Eternal Ascent
but without further Ado guys let's hop
into some weekly challenge art hit it
sto
all right are we doing uh winners first
or honorables first so what do you think
winners
first all right let's see let me get my
let me get my stuff figured
out sweet all right guys so um our first
winner starting with the
winners is let's take a look who do we
got we got
l42 W with this super cool render you
put together from this beautiful
painting
here great concept uh the original yeah
Absolut all these originals are
incredible um but we're here to talk
about these Recreations that you guys
did and I think you did a solid job with
your lighting matching that lighting it
looks really nice very crisp uh high
contrast your V your vignette that
you're using around the edges here
definitely draws the eye to toward the
night and toward that girl with the
flower um your render quality is on
point background's on point you just
knocked it out the park this is a great
example of nice lighting it looks Punchy
very crispy the render settings are
cranked up very very important when you
have time to add more render settings do
it or uh samples rather do
it um that's a good point for this
challenge here for the monthly challenge
save yourself time in the end for for uh
for rendering for final looks for
rendering even all right but we'll get
into that in the later streams in the
month but congratulations l42 W for
winning this week's weekly challenge
next up guys next up we have
Maurice this is so funny to me I love
this um what an incredible Recreation it
wasn't in a direct
Recreation but it was you know you took
your own spin on it and I think it's
hilarious makes me laugh I think it's a
perfect Recreation you did a great job
you made it your own um it looks photo
real the lighting's incredible the story
is incredible uh I thought it was a
great Twist on the original so
congratulations
there next up we got under what's up
under dude this is
insane it's so so good that render you
really captured the Lush nature of the
original reference
um which is it takes a lot of work guys
it takes a lot of work you think uh
enough's enough and then you know you
know what you got to add more especially
with nature stuff and dude your lighting
is on point man it's super creamy looks
beautiful like I don't know I don't know
if I have anything else to say about
that man it's just really nice
congratulations under and since under
since you are a new moderator by the way
everyone welcome under as a new
moderator um you're going to give your
challenge winner roll which all of these
winners are getting which unlocks the
lounge all that stuff you're going to
give that to one of the honorable
mentions that we're going to get to
later all the winners also get 15 points
towards their rank on the server we have
like Pokemon badges but for art on the
Discord side it's super fun um honorable
mentions get five points and if you
participate in the weeklys you get a
point as well um next up we got
visual look at that dude dude freaking
beautiful the lighting and the render
quality is top top top notch really cool
painting love the abstract nature of it
but you just went you know very photo
real with with your interpretation I
love it um visual uses Daz to create
most of his art um he also uses c4d and
octane to finalize everything but you're
looking at Dazz characters here um lit
and rendered in in Octane c4d and man
you you knock it out the park every time
your lighting is incredible giant
softbox from the top like I'm such a big
fan of that kind of look and I think you
really killed
it and our last winner is one that we
had to blur it's not as bad as it looks
but go to Discord to check the winner um
it's beautiful we would just get flagged
on YouTube The Stream would probably get
knocked down um it's not technically
nudity it's just a lot of skin that's
all um go check it out so
congratulations to AA 12 for winning
that it's beautiful go check it out
Discord side right after the stream all
right we got honorable mentions to get
into so let's begin first up we have
wondrous this one came so close to
winning dude cuz technically it's a
perfect Recreation perfect render um I
have no complaints except for the grass
that Clips through the road in the
foreground that's the only thing only
thing I'll give you a hard time about it
because I know you and um I don't know
where I'm going with that but I'm just
giving you a hard time the only reason
to me that this this came so close is
just cuz you know I've seen a lot of
Simon Stalin hag in the
past um whereas the other Recreations I
had are they were a bit more new to me
even though I love the style love that
foggy overcast style if it was another
judge you probably would have won um so
shout outs to you next up we got
Alvi really cool um shoot what's that
guy's name the main art shoot uh melting
clocks is that same
artist it's not mcer it's uh art history
guys uh maybe yeah I don't know
um regardless it's incredible I love it
uh it's really unique think about
painting this though is the crazy part
to me is like who who would have thought
the artist who painted it would have
thought and if I can remember their name
you would know them some of you probably
already know them in chat if you know
them please type their name I appreciate
it uh but it's a classic it's a classic
and I think you did a great job with
this it's really awesome how you put
this together I'd be very curious to see
how you did it is it just projection
mapping could
be but man what a cool look anti cricks
is
next really nice rendition um to me it's
your lighting that shines here you did a
good job matching it um the sheets do
seem a little thin um paper thin almost
and I think when you take a close look
at it it could use a little thickness
but I think you you really knocked out
the the textures the lighting the pose I
think is great um so I wanted to shout
you out there we got hey Mr who next
wanted shout you out this is beautiful
to me I love this so much it's very
simple but it's really really cool I
love
this um yeah I just want one of those in
my house I love it congratulations
manishka is next as an honorable mention
just a great Recreation really cool
striking image good choice of a painting
to
recreate um I think it's very fun you
captured it very nicely and uh yeah I
can't say anymore great job meow is
next this one almost won to
me um it was close it was really close
but boy do I love that that uh the
original is incredible and so is the
recreation it's just so Lush I love the
colors it's
beautiful I think a lot of
us relate to these kind of shots this
kind of art because of that fantasy
element of being in the soft grass with
the big clouds in a blue sky is just
it's
beautiful um so good stuff there
metatrox is
next you recreated a uh a classic indeed
and uh it's even an animation you can
catch the whole thing on server side or
even here hey look at that sod mon
sodon's playing it out um I think it's
metahuman right you're a big unreal guy
um you did a nice Recreation there got
some
silly little voice uh what is
it my this is when I stream too long
this one I can't think of vocal capture
motion capture with the voice adding
some
uh audio clip yeah I'm just I'm I'm
bombing here
guys great job on the recreation the
metat TR noodle you're
next crazy art dude a crazy original
crazy
Recreation super intense um but a really
awesome Recreation you put together love
the uh black and white nature of it the
original man is awesome it's just
freaking sweet it's really
intense but I wanted to shout you up cuz
he did a great job on that Recreation
there scratch you're next we got four
more five more for you guys this this is
super cool really great job matching the
values of the original um really cool
image great choice of a painting to
recreate
um yeah I love it that lighting is
freaking awesome love that black and
white Vibe good stuff game Factory
you're next you actually you you went
Above and Beyond on this in the sense
that you really took that interpretation
and made it your own I love that um I
would say Loosely inspired by which I
think is a cool thing so congrats on
that man I love the super rainy overcast
Vibes of it I think you did a really
nice job on that horse especially in
Endless engines I remember you you hand
animating horses all month and I think
it paid off here cuz it looks amazing I
don't know if you hand animated or what
whether you used stock horse assets you
learned your lesson perhaps cuz it looks
great no matter how you're doing it it
looks great uh next up we we have why ma
Moshi apologies on the butcher
there but really nice Recreation dude U
it all hand modeled except for the snake
head you said uh believe in
blender and I think you nailed it yeah
you nailed the
style is very reminiscent of I don't
know whatever that style is I don't know
where that is placed in history in my
mind but I know I've seen it before and
I think it's super cool man
you did a great job wle is second to
last or no you're the last one wle you
made this awesome Recreation of this uh
fruit
bowl that's not fruit that's those are
veggies and little dude I know until
sodon mentioned it if you flip them
upside down is actually a face in the
veggies and it's kind of the creepiest
thing I've ever seen I would not want
this sneaking around my bedroom at night
you look on the right you can really
tell the mushrooms are the
lips the giant like turnup or carrot
thing on on the left is the nose and the
eyes there is just
disgusting uh uh
uh I don't like
it but I love the render very good stuff
congrats to the winers congrats to the
honorable mentions you guys killed it I
can't wait to see what you guys do on
this 3D Community challenge Eternal
Ascent popping off through March but
let's get back to the chat let's see
where you guys are at
here I'll hang out for the next 5 10
minutes answer any questions you have
any last minute questions that you guys
have so let's get this chat front and
center and see what uh see what's going
on are you guys feeling pretty confident
about this one how many of you guys feel
like you have an idea
that has some fruit to it that has some
potential by a show of hands who has an
idea and if you don't have an idea give
me
um a question mark
Emoji I want to see the balance here I
feel like I'm somewhere in the middle
I'm skeptical to believe that my idea is
the idea right now but I am happy that
there is some sort of direction if you
don't have a Direction That's okay
though
um it can take a week to get the the
thing you're going for right but let's
keep looking at reference coming up with
different ideas if you Journal about it
too um I find that free writing about
things really helps me think but we have
a nice set of hands here we got some
question marks here it's a good
mix um if it's a question mark don't
feel like you're behind guys it's
literally day one hour three it's going
to be
okay um Infinity monk do you have to use
the given animation or can you custom
make a new one and does the character
need to be a
humanoid yes you need to use the given
animation you're locked into the given
animation we talked about
some um exceptions to that
rule which are if you want the character
holding something or if you want their
arms to be like maybe a flag or whatever
you can move the
arms um and you can move the head you
can move the Gaze but you can't change
the steps you can't change the frequency
of their of their steps or their hips or
anything like that leave the lower body
leave it the same if you have to move a
little bit of arms or head to support
your story go for it but no you can't
just bust out some random animation of
the character doing a butt scoot up the
stairs or walking backwards or sitting
on the stairs or running up the stairs
out of frame no look at the previous
challenges um such as alternate
realities that's a great example that's
the character walking sideways every
person used the same map data that was a
situation where you could change the
hands and the head as well but you would
notice that that didn't break the flow
of the render um or of the Montage right
it kept the flow moving forward and
that's what we want to do here the
reason that you're all locked into the
same animation is to keep the flow of
the Montage moving and looping at all
times if you choose some random other
animation it breaks it okay
um I'm just scrolling down here hit me
with at pisher it's a little easier to
see
um hey
o oh
saart you listen to the podcast with
that I did with bad decisions U bad
decision Studios and you really liked it
man that's super cool I'm glad you
enjoyed it I still got a blast that
interview out I think it'll be a good
time to do it cuz we talked a lot about
these 3D challenges ways to win ways to
hop into them and ways to stay positive
and inspired throughout the whole time
so um that's definitely something I need
to do thank you for that I'm glad you
enjoyed
it Matthew is the too negative frame in
the blender file missing I can't find it
and a few people also said it's missing
on
Discord so negative one frame there's no
negative one frame um if you don't see a
negative 1 frame then what we did for
you is we have an in the references
folder in the project files there is the
roko T pose and that's what that's what
you need open up that fpx that Roco te
pose drop that into your scene there you
go um I also have a mixo t pose just for
the people who are going to be using
mixo I got that in there just to help
you out as well but I'll look into the
minus one frame not being in blender for
sure I'll make a note of that right here
right now you can also select the rig
and and on its settings click rest
position and you should get the T POS
that way also but yeah we'll look into
it thanks
Soo
um all right let's see going down the
list does it need a loop um no I don't
think your render will be a true loop
with invis with an invisible cut point
no no no um all that matters is that
your render flows in with the next
person's render and that's happening via
everyone using the same animation that's
happening via you not touching the
camera and that's happening via um
keeping the visual weight of the stairs
intact uh throughout all of the the
submissions right those are the three
those are the three rules and those are
the three things that are going to help
you help ensure all the renders flow
into each other like I said look at the
previous montages that we've done here
if you look on my playlists on my
channel you can find the 3D render
montage playlist and you'll see all the
top 100 montages you'll see the all the
all renders montages that'll give you a
very good idea of where we're going with
this um or you know those of you who
have done these challenges before also
on the Discord side help people out who
um who don't know right this may be
their first one you guys have done them
before help those people out you guys
are in a position to do
so um can you give us a whole story time
with what happened with corridor or did
you sign an NDA so no there's no NDA
it's literally it's just when you I
assume when you're saying what happened
with Corridor you're talking about me
leaving Corridor dude what is in that
video of my leaving video that Corridor
posted that's exactly what happened like
there's no I'm not uh making stuff up
there's no like dark secrets it's
literally what I say in that video so go
check that out if you want to but
the short of it is I just wanted to do
my own thing that's it
um let's
see nothing asks can the animation of
the stairs be slightly changed but the
timing of the character step stepping
and everything stays the same so like
instead of stairs moving smoothly they
they have
mechanical
um so if I'm getting you right uh yes
yes as long as the character animation
is the same they're taking the same
height steps all that stuff like the
stairs is a big part of you know it's
ready for your artistic spin on the
stairs so change the stairs to however
you want I'm probably going to make it
some like brick thing with some rocks
and leaves and twigs sticking out and
like probably that'll be my
interpretation of this you can add a
guardrail make a metal whatever right
that's the whole point make make it fun
spice it up zest it
up um can you use re Illusions character
creator for the workflow you can use
whatever program you guys want
100% oh yeah hidden Force good point um
VFX artist react there's an episode that
came out
today um we watched all the Indiana
Jones movies and did a bfx artist react
on all the Indiana Jones movies I
watched the the original trilogy me and
my wife got together watched them all um
I read all the sin effects articles on
it these massive like 30-page articles
and I come to the table with all the
good info on um the original trilogy
Indiana Jones and then Ren and Nico they
talk about the new ones so go check it
out that's on Corridor side came out
today dropped this morning let's
see decks do I ever struggle with taking
the first steps on a project if so any
tips to push forward and start yeah I'd
say starting is the hardest part um well
no I don't know starting starting is a
hard part it's like getting out of bed
getting out of
bed if you don't have something you're
looking forward
to um then it it can be difficult that
can be the hardest part of the day if
you're trying to say go to a workout in
the morning getting out of bed
and committing yourself to that workout
is the hardest part the workout isn't
the hardest part it's getting out of bed
and going to the workout is the hardest
part getting started right so in this
case for a lot of us getting started um
and I want to make it as exciting as
possible for you guys that's why I'm
doing the live stream that's why it's a
big announcement video big Community
where I want to get you guys as excited
as possible to get started CU that is a
hurdle for sure for a lot of us
um I think there's a difficulty in
deciding what you want to do it's kind
of
like it's kind of opposite usually you
have an idea for something you want to
do and then you decide to do it in this
case it's like hey there's an
opportunity to do
something but there's no
idea so we hope that the the the the the
ref not the reference the template
inspires something in your brain when
you look at it you can see something
right and it's a big environment so take
a look at some environments um go for a
hike even right a lot of us just default
to scrolling on the internet as our
reference but that's why I love you know
these art books flipping through all
these different art books and stuff for
reference is um you know I have a small
collection of art books here for that
reason exactly it's a great way to get
the brain juices flowing um but yeah go
for a walk go for a hike
think about these things in the back of
your mind and um give yourself some
patience and know that in time you'll
come up with something in time you'll
come up with something free writing also
helps I mentioned earlier um what if I
did this what if I did that what if I
did this that that right and you just
think of as many ideas as
possible
um finding tutorials for yourself that
that uh help answer questions we're all
going to be troubleshooting this this is
the troubleshooting 3D challenge guys
there's a lot of troubleshooting when it
comes to 3D so try and enjoy that time a
lot of us can get
frustrated especially on a deadline we
can get very frustrated with
troubleshooting so I think if we're if
we're committing x amount of hours per
day to this
challenge um and you're slowly chipping
away at it as opposed to just rushing
everything at the end you'll have a
better time of it you'll make room for
getting stuck overcoming Hur and we'll
get through a lot of that through
consistency sticking with it so I don't
know there's a lot lot of thoughts on
that but hopefully that helps
[Music]
you um Davos good question can you
change the size of the character a bit
so I believe this is an
FAQ if you go to the get started channel
on
Discord but
um technically
no you can't change the size of the
character but let's say for instance you
are retargeting a giant onto the map
data but they don't look giant anymore
because the way the steps you know the
size of the steps you can adjust the
size of the steps to be
like like imagine right it's like a
giant walking up these
steps and each step they're taking would
be in relation right as long as the
giant is the same size as the template
file character on screen then you're
good you would just need to build the
step set out so that the steps are like
buildings and they're taking they're
like stepping over buildings or like
giant chunks of mountain or rock and
then you have like normal siiz
characters maybe climbing the mountain
to show that this is a giant so in that
sense you can change the scale but no
you can't like make them really tall or
really small same if you're if you're
retarding like like a dwarf character
onto the map data you know the stairs
would essentially
be bigger they'd still be stepping in
the same way right the moap data would
still be stepping in the same way you
would just make if you wanted to make it
a miniature scene those steps would be
like popsicle sticks or something right
so as long as the character takes up the
same space as the character in the
template file you can play with scale in
that sense if that makes sense to you
[Music]
can you make water flow down the steps
why not
[Music]
absolutely um bratique you're asking are
the steps in the staircase meant to be
the same size now this is also an FAQ a
lot of the FAQs are on character and and
stairs right that's natural um do they
all have to be the same size
technically
no but what does need to be the same
size are the steps that the character is
taking that map data is baked in right
so you need to make sure that those
steps they're taking those four steps
they're taking are equal equal steps but
if you want to have some of the bottom
steps or the top
steps kind
of um like say they're going up like a
mountain path right I keep using this
mountain path example like 80 million
mountain path examples or renders
um let's say like these four steps these
four equal steps they're taking are like
four stones that are equally spaced but
then like up ahead you can see that the
steps might get bigger right and the
ones below get smaller or something like
that or bigger whatever so you can play
with like the sizing of the steps um as
long as the character is stepping you're
not as long as you're not touching the
the map data right like you can't have
them skip two steps make a big step like
no no no keep that map data
in
um can you add buildings or any other
elements on the right side of the stairs
yeah absolutely that would be cool like
put put something in that in that little
Nook on the right that would be
sick
so a lot of you guys have questions on
like can I break the
stairs um can I change the width of the
steps all of that
stuff technically all of this is okay
but again keep in mind that before you a
person is going to have steps leading up
to your render so if you start it with
no steps then it's kind of It kind of
breaks it also if you have no
steps leading out of your
render then the person after you their
steps coming down like it's like Steps
will just appear so keep that in mind
keep that in
mind but you can play with the steps
it's up to you you're not you're the
artist play with the
steps
um but but look at that second rule I
think it's the second rule it's either
second or third rule in the project file
is maintain the visual weight of the
steps so if you're just going to do thin
little glass footprint steps that are
floating in the sky that's technically
not adhering to that rule you need to
find a way to fill
out that space in the frame with
something thing that resembles or
resembled some steps um I guess that's
the best way I could put it right
now wondrous what's up
dude yes wondrous I can't wait I can't
wait for what you put together dude it's
going to be sick it's challenge time
baby you got
it you got it wondrous has been a uh
been on the server for a while now the
Discord server
so it's good to see you here good to see
you here man he'll help you guys out
he'll be making some cool stuff that's
for
sure all
right uh so if there is some landing and
characters so that covers the visual way
the
stairs I guess I don't quite understand
question manishka oh oh Christian what
up son what up
Christian dude I got to watch that VFX
artist react episode I'm excited for
that that was a good one very fun um
good to see you dude good to see you
shout outs to you
dude Tetris steps all right I love it I
love
it let me hear you guys' ideas what um
what kind of ideas are you guys trying
to go for this time what are you what
are you trying to learn what ideas are
you trying to implement let me hear it
and then we'll call
it can you add more characters yes you
can add more characters as long as the
provided one um is the main
subject two questions do we add custom
backgrounds outside of steps outside the
steps yes absolutely it's a it's a
coloring book page that you got to color
in and then can you replace the walking
with other animation no you
cannot all right if the character's
wearing a long skirt that covers even
the
foot yeah is it okay if the character's
body language is a little different from
the way the Moab character is
walking um I don't know It's Tricky
one I don't know how you would do that
without messing with with just without
making entirely new moap data I don't
know that's an artistic risk that you
might have to take
all right Royal plutonians doing a war
scene we got some Harry Potter steps AZ
Tech
mythology
yep Howen you just started playing
around this time and you're going to see
what comes up instead
of instead of just okay I got you you're
going to start playing around this time
and see what I like instead of waiting
for the perfect idea I think that's a
good good way to go about it Tetris
steps um
um Sandro you're going to make some
massive underwater Atlantis City I think
that's super cool I love
it tin Coco you have no idea but you're
going to hit that brainstorm shower very
soon that's a powerful
shower I got to say it's a good one Elli
what's up um having an office space
destroyed by time and space Vortex thing
that sounds cool I love
that Unk games your brain is empty that
is good you're you're ahead of us all
it's perfect it's where you want to
be got little Kung Fu Panda climb some
steps yeah yeah yeah Final Fantasy I
love it can you change the main
character animation no can I replace the
how can I replace the default character
um so on Friday the 9th this upcoming
Friday when I'm I'm going to be live
streaming this whole month every Friday
and this this next one I'm doing with
Sam from roko and we're going to be
talking about how to replace all the
characters um so maybe focus on your
environment a little bit before you
worry about the character if you want to
wait for that live stream otherwise
there's tutorials out there um Lots good
info but I'll see you guys Friday for
that to help you with uh retargeting and
all that
stuff maintenance walk uh worker walking
alongside oh I lost
it
I like maintenance worker
though um we're walking alongside a
Pneumatic elevator is all I've got so
far I think that's
cool is there a 3D creation website I'd
recommend yeah there's a lot um so poly
Haven is a great free resource for free
textures free hdis and free models um if
you're in Unreal Engine
uh the whole quick soulle library comes
for
free
um let's see all the sponsors uh we have
for prizes you can check in the link in
the description you can also check on
the Discord side we have all the prizes
listed out um so like Roco vision for
example is free you guys can grab that
uh it's a 14-day free trial but you can
email support roco.com with the subject
line Punisher 3D Challenge and they'll
reup you
um your 14-day free trial of Roco Vision
that is basically a way to motion
capture your own performance without a
motion capture suit and it uses two
cameras to capture that data um so
that's a good
resource um Jenga effects is providing
their suite for free for the month for
you guys so that's embergen if you want
to make explosions smoke dust particles
um you know tornadoes Sparks fog clouds
all that stuff embergen is uh basically
a
GPU based Sim software that you can
simulate in real time uh they also came
out geogen and that's their terrain
generator all real time um you know you
can look at your render as you create it
that's all free this month the link is
in the description down below Jenga
effects go check them out uh gr skill
gorilla go check them out they're also a
sponsor of this challenge they have if
you go to their website uh sign up on
their website it's free and you can grab
some free assets from them uh to use in
your art as well I would also recommend
they're not a sponsor this time but
they're an incredible resource kit bash
3D go to Kit bash 3D I'm telling you
guys this is probably one of the best
ones here go to Kit bash 3D um they have
cargo they just came out with cargo it's
basically their asset Library you don't
have to buy individual packs any anymore
you can just get cargo and buy uh
individual assets you can say I want to
buy this giant Temple for five bucks you
can do that um you can of course still
buy packs too
but they have a big free asset Library
so go to Kit bash 3D um I got a link
down below uh I should have a link down
below for Kit bash and stuff if not I'm
going to add one but go to kitat 3D grab
cargo it's they have a free version and
um a lot of good stuff over
there anything else what i s mon would
you recommend any
like 3D asset stuff can you think of
anything I think you got them I mean
YouTube is good for Learning
and blender.org I
guess they're all good yeah what you
said is good yeah um if you guys are an
Unreal Engine uh I have a lot of great
Unreal Engine tutorials I'm going to be
streaming an Unreal Engine throughout
this month helping you guys out uh
William fche also has some incredible
tutorials Winbush has some incredible
unreal
tutorials um Cinema 4 du wi gray scale
gorilla they're like the tops uh David
arv a lot of
octane um c4d tutorials you got I design
EJ over at ID design he's got some
incredible c4d
tutorials
um who
else blender wise I like you guys are on
blender blender Guru of course the
doughnut tutorial and
Beyond um CG geek has got some good ones
um sod mon who am I missing I'm not on
the blender
side H yeah I don't know I don't
know um
I bad normals also does some good
stuff
um yeah I don't know you guys help me
out here in chat guys if you guys know
of any good blender tutorials blender
YouTube artists who make good
stuff oh captain disolution of course
he's less of a Click by click guy and
more of a overall kind of um you know
workflow debunking type of guy he gets
into Theory a little bit and he's one of
the best oh yeah Ian Hubert of course
Ian Hubert he's got some tutorials
sprinkled out um CG boost I'm seeing
guys CG
matter
um chip Walters for blender okay yeah
good stuff good stuff default
Cube yeah there's some good resources
down here
guys please add seagulls flying to the
left of the stairs I'll think about it
my friend I will think about it but it's
not a bad idea I like
it
oh yeah Peter France duh Peter France go
check out Peter France he's got
incredible tutorials they're like super
in-depth good dude he's coming over
tonight actually we're doing a little uh
Katan night at the place Peter's coming
over some other friends
[Music]
too all right y'all I think that's it I
think we're going to call it I'll see
you on the Discord side good luck for
those of you who know uh what's going on
you know what you're doing help those
who
don't um I'll see you guys Monday on
Discord at noon for the weekly uh stage
chat we'll get you guys up on stage talk
about your ideas maybe talk about your
blockouts take a look at your stuff and
uh I will I will be here for you to
further guide everyone toward um a super
cool unifying Montage that we'll all
have in the end of this thing in March
it's when it's dropping guys you have
until March 3rd 11:59 p.m. PST all right
March 3rd that's a Sunday 11:59 p.m
PST not a second pass all right it's a
it's a sad
thing to have to drop the uh the artists
who submit a minute after that deadline
don't let it happen to you but we're not
there yet we're in the beginning so stay
inspired um keep your eyes and yours
peeled for inspiration don't get hooked
on just the one idea I'm going to do a
little bit of research myself and see if
I can't come up with another idea as
well but
um other than that guys good luck have
fun I'll see you on Monday on Discord
and then next Friday with Sam from roko
we'll be showing you guys how to add
characters to the map data retarget all
that good stuff but until then I'll see
you guys later good luck have fun peace
[Music]
he